Tanigaki is a serious
man.If you don't get into the story of trying to outsmart Tsurumi's attention, you think that even though you
nailed Corporal Tamai, the
egg birds failed to persuade
him, and they tried to shut their mouths, and they were defeated.  But it's only natural
Tanigaki must have been waiting for Tsurumi's recovery to go tell Tsurumi about our lawlessness.
It's an excellent infantry gun, but
it's difficult for an average soldier
to inflict a fatal wound at 100 meters away.  I had a hard time with the raw finish. If I had
made a stage that was good at precision shooting like me, I
should have been able to do it without dying.
[MUSIC]
Judging from the way they talk,
that's the only reason they want
to kill me.After all, the 7th Division is a collection of hodgepodges that flowed from all over
Japan.The roots may be fragile Tsurumi Chuu.
Does
it mean that there is a person who intends to betray his attention?Who is that?
Kah, I didn't know the lost child leader was going to betray Tsurumi's attention
.